this is what's important they think
Einstein was sort of working this vacuum
they all think theorist is are alone at
night just coming up with things but he
was tied to observation and experiment
he wrote down this beautiful Theory but
that didn't give him palpitations even
though it was beautiful and he once said
if he knew could be wrong because was so
beautiful when he did the calculation
for general relativity and discovered
something called the parhelion of
mercury and he did the calculation
general relativity and it came up with
the exact number that people had
observed that's when he said he had
heart palpitations and almost fainted it
was really realizing that he had agreed
with observation and physics isn't done
in this vacuum it depends on the
observations of the time very very
rarely theorists lead